bonjour bonjour c'est la journée de
l'europe comme tous les ans le 9 mai si
vous étiez médecin quel bilan de santé
de réfugiés ou de l'europe
je dirais que on est dans un moment
paradoxale au fond on voit bien que le
fonctionnement de l'europe tout ça ne va
pas je vais revenir dans une seconde et
en même temps jamais on n'a eu autant
besoin d'une réponse européenne aux
différents défis ça c'est ce que disent
les européens convaincus comme ça va pas
il faut plus d'europe
il faut mieux d'europe plus il faut
mieux d'europe savez c'est rare que je
cite le pape françois ne veut pas de
francs soit un grand discours sur
l'europe que j'habite aux auditeurs
allez allez regarder à l'occasion du
prix charlemagne de l'européen qu'il a
reçu vendredi il a dit faut un
changement radical
il a dit il faut retrouver une âme ça
moi j'ai retrouvé un idéal c'est la
vérité renouer avec un humanisme
européen et la raison est donc oui bien
sûr faut pas seulement une refondation
bien sûr qu'on voit bien que on peut
reparler zone euro intégration mai mais
tout ça ce sont des mécanismes au fond
et donc il ya un moment il faut
peut-être laissé les mécanismes de koné
essayer de renouer de retrouver ce qui
fait la substance essentielle de
l'europe c'est-à-dire cette idée que
nous avons que bien au fond ensemble
nous avons un avenir commun et un dessin
des moyens de faire rêver l'europe au
web et à ses traits indien d amour
aujourd'hui ses profondes
il ya un besoin de nombreux pays et un
besoin d'europe quand on pose la
question on dit bah oui bien sûr on voit
bien que l'europe devrait pouvoir
répondre à toutes ces questions par
exemple la question des réfugiés et en
même temps on voit que ce lien de
confiance il n'est pas là il est pas là
bas pour une raison simple c'est qu'il
ya pas de démocratie européenne
véritable saignée que le citoyen les
citoyens ils n'ont pas le sentiment de
pouvoir peser sur les direction que
prennent l'europe sur la politique
européenne
alors je pense que ceux qui partent une
porte une part de ce qu'ils peuvent
pardon une part de responsabilité
extrêmement importante ce sont les chefs
d'état et gouvernement
très franchement qu'ils sont
pour les uns dans les égoïsmes nationaux
pour les autres qui impose décide à la
place des autres
mais en même temps c'est à eux d'assumer
cette histoire européenne et cette idée
européenne comme françois hollande je
prends un exemple donne mandat à la
commission d'aller négocier avec les
états unis
sans en parler au précédent à 106 sur le
traité transatlantique sans avoir saisi
l'opinion publique française en disant
écoutez dans quelques mois je vais
donner mandat à la commission
je veux qu'on en débatte d'abord chez
nous ils portent une part de
responsabilité importante
son prédécesseur c'était la même chose
donc il va falloir une transformation
radicale de ce point de vue là pour cela
je crains qu'il faille attendre
probablement les prochaines élections
présidentielles en france
le parlement grec a adopté hier de
nouvelles mesures réclamées par ses
créanciers dont l'europe en particulier
nouvelle baisse des pensions de retraite
abaissement du seuil de revenus à partir
duquel on devient imposable des milliers
de personnes avaient manifesté
auparavant pour dénoncer ces nouvelles
mesures d'austérité on a quand même
l'impression propos de la grèce que ça
ne s'arrêtera jamais qu'il faudra
toujours une nouvelle saignée la
question ça fait six ans on fait
pourtant je continue de le dire ce n'est
pas une bonne politique
alors est ce que les grecs ont des
responsabilités dans ce qui se passe oui
il n'ya pas déteindre est qu on voit
bien que c'est compliqué je parle pas
l'histoire du cadastre des impôts que
l'église ne paye pas les armateurs ne
paye pas on connaît tout ça maintenant
depuis 5 6 ans que que les uns et les
autres entendent sur ce qui se passe en
grèce
mais enfin c'est pas uniquement comme ça
avec ce type de mes yeux qu'on y arrive
on devrait se poser la question de
savoir comment on renoue comme en aide à
l'activité économique en grèce quelles
perspectives on donne en grèce avec
évidemment des réformes qui devraient
leur ensemble mais on peut pas faire
d'un côté ce qu'on appelle entre
guillemets l'austérité tous les jours de
plus en plus sur les pinsons sur les
retraites sur les salaires sans donner
aucune perspective un peuple
ça n'est pas aussi ça c'est une femme
que le peuple à conakry qui a jugé chris
te ment aux comptables ou en liquidateur
judiciaire
c'est une co responsabilité européenne
il ya une deuxième erreur pour moi mais
c'est une erreur depuis le début c'est
d'avoir une famille donc où est la
vérité l'europe aurait dû pouvoir régler
cette question grecque sans faire appel
au fmi
alors le paradoxe est qu aujourd'hui le
fmi demande d'un côté des mesures
additionnelles je pense que ça ça ne va
pas mais de l'autre côté il dîne faut
juste que oui il faudra pour une partie
de la dette renégociée évidemment on
prête pour que les grecs puissent
rembourser
c'est pas comme ça qui font des réformes
et c'est pas comme ça qu'ils tournent
les perspectives est ce que vous êtes
favorable aux mécanismes de sanction
financière proposé il ya quelques jours
par la commission européenne pour les
pays qui ne respectent pas les quotas
d'accueil de migrants 250000 euros par
migrants n'ont accueilli
je trouve que c'est un crédible
totalement et que c'est pas de bonne
politique que la commission propose ce
type de mesures il faut évidemment une
solidarité mais il faut reprendre les
choses avant c'est évident que on voit
bien que l'europe là tu baala est là
elle a loupé le coche ça fait des années
qu'on a ces guerres en suisse a fait
cinq ans moi je suis allé dans les camps
que ce soit en turquie en jordanie au
liban il ya trois ans il ya quatre ans
la question des réfugiés elle n'est pas
arrivée comme ça du jour au lendemain et
dernière ça fait cinq ans qu'elle est là
que le repas était incapable de regarder
en face de se doter d'une politique
commune d'asile et d'assumer oui il
fallait qu'on dise nous sommes très
recevoir une partie pas tout le monde
mais une partie des réfugiés syriens
faisons le par des voies légales
organisons le alors dans les camps
faisant en sorte que les demandes de
visa se passe dans les camps de réfugiés
après on répond favorablement ou non
répondent négativement et en même temps
contrôles aux frontières
bref nous n'avons pas eu de politique et
de règles communes c'est ça qu'il
fallait la marque à la source et la
nécessité sont pas des basques de la
marque n'a pas forcé la main
nous on paie en ouvrant grand ses
frontières si elle a forcé la main moi
je pense qu'il n'aurait pas fallu le
faire comme ça c'est à dire qu'avant et
elle a dit on reçoit personnes à presles
et elle a dit on reçoit tout le monde je
pense qu'on pouvait faire quelque chose
qui aurait été plus équilibré et en même
temps moi je vous dis comme je le pense
comme citoyenne elle a quand même sauvé
en grande partie le 9 l'union européenne
c'est à dire qu'au moins a compris que
là il y avait un enjeu je pense qu'il
fallait pas le gérer de cette façon là
si vous laissez faire sans organiser
sans réguler etc
vous êtes très très vite débordés très
vite dépassés c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
s'est passé vous pouvez pas intégré
comme ça à des dizaines de milliers de
personnes en même temps
vous êtes obligés de le faire de façon
organisée ça n'a pas été fait très
s'organiser c'est dommage
comme tu es bout de la présidentielle de
2017 rend ce verrou est toujours dans la
tente de ce qui va se passer à la
prévert de la drogue pour se déterminer
moi je pense que 2010 est c'est une
échéance fondamentales dont la france
parce que c'est une chance et c'est
fondamental pour l'europe et pour le
monde
on voit tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en france qui se passe en europe on a
besoin d'une présidence de la république
forte on a besoin de redresser le pays
c'est pourquoi nous soutenons et
françois bayrou a soutient alain juppé
c'est rare un homme politique de premier
plan qui est crédité de 13 à 15% dans
les sondages qui écoutait moi je
soutiens quelqu'un qui n'est pas de ma
famille politique mais je pense qu'alain
juppé peut y arriver parce que il a
pousé depuis le début que il sera un
candidat de rassemblement c'est à dire
qu'il ne serait pas un président de la
république s'il était choisi au primaire
s'il est élu partisans et je pense que
c'est ça qui est très important pour
l'avenir
mais si alain juppé m'emporter pas
candidat du coup serait un candidat sans
grande détermination lavande id nous
l'avons dit depuis le premier jour je
crois que vous vous trompez totalement
ne l'avons dit depuis le premier jour
nous serons libres mais je trouve que
donnons-lui crédit moi je lui donne
crédit d'être en capacité
c'est rare chez l homme poli de soutenir
quelqu'un tu n'es pas forcément de sa
famille politique
mais nous devons nous avec françois
bayrou porter deux exigences cette
exigence de rassemblement parce que
c'est absolument comme ça qu'on voudrait
c'est un pays et n'exigeant soucier de
changements profonds
de la manière dont ont besoin les pays
merci mario de ce 1er mai